foreign
good afternoon everybody
I have a few things at the top
everybody okay so I wanted to provide
you an update on our efforts to support
the people of Jackson and the state of
Mississippi
the president spoke with the mayor of
Jackson this morning
and the FEMA Administration
administrator also spoke with the
governor the president last night also
immediately approved the governor's
emergency declaration request directing
his team to Surge assistance to the
state
FEMA has personal on Personnel on site
in the state Emergency Operations Center
and is coordinating with State emergency
management team to identify specific
resource requirements the Environmental
Protection Agency is deploying a subject
matter expert to support the emergency
assessment of the Jackson water
treatment plants and is working to
expedite delivery of experiment sorry
equipment needed to repair Jackson's
Water Treatment Plant we are committed
to helping the people of Jackson and the
Mississippi and the state of Mississippi
during this urgent time of need
we are saddened by the tragic loss of
life and destruction as a result of the
severe flooding in Pakistan we sent our
deepest condolences to all the
individuals and families impacted the
United States stands with communities in
Pakistan as they experience severe
flooding and landslides yesterday usaid
announced it is providing an additional
30 million dollars in humanitarian
assistance to support the people
affected by the severe flooding with
these funds usaid Partners will
prioritize urgently needed support for
FL for food nutrition
Safe Water
improve sanitation and hygiene and
shelter assistance a usaid disaster
management specialist is also in
Islamabad to assess the impact of the
floods and to determine additional
humanitarian assistance that the U.S
government May provide
the United States has and will continue
to be a strong supporter of the people
of Pakistan we are the we are the single
largest humanitarian donor to Pakistan
having provided over 33 million dollars
in humanitarian assistance we will
continue to closely monitor the
situation in Pakistan for further needs
following this horrific tragedy
also this morning we announced new
public and private sector actions to
strengthen the teaching profession and
support schools as they address teacher
shortages the new efforts include
commitments from leading job platforms
such as such as zip recruiter indeed and
handshake to make it easier for
Americans to find teaching opportunities
they include new initiatives from
teacher unions and organizations to
expand high quality Pathways into the
teaching profession secretary cordona
and secretary Walsh also sent a letter
to State and local leaders outlining a
series of actions they can take to
support teachers and schools and earlier
this afternoon first lady Jill Biden
domestic policy advisor Susan Rice
secretary Cardona and secretary Walsh
met with public and private sector
leaders here at the White House they
discuss short and long-term strategies
to address the teacher shortage and the
action and the president has already
taken to address long-standing Staffing
challenges facing our schools
[Applause]
30 billion dollars the president secured
through the American Rescue plan for
school districts across the country to
hire retain and support teachers we are
committed to addressing the teacher
shortage and giving students families
and Educators the resources they need
for a successful and safe school year
this year
and lastly I want to take a moment to
recognize International overdose
Awareness Day according to the Centers
for Disease Control and prevention more
than a hundred and seven thousand
Americans tragically died from a drug
overdose in 2021. today the second
gentleman and Dr Gupta the director of
The White House Office of National Drug
control policy will meet with families
from across the country who have lost
loved ones to deadly drugs like illicit
Fentanyl
for for far too many years the overdose
epidemic has been destroying American
lives and causing pain and heartbreak
for families across the country as the
president said in the State of the Union
beating the overdose overdose epidemic
is a key part of his agenda the
president's strategy expands access to
high impact Public Health Services while
reducing the supply of illicit drugs
like fentanyl
as part of that strategy the Department
of Health and Human Services announced
today around 8 80 million dollars in
Grants to support prevention and
treatment for substance use and overdose
prevention while this funding will help
communities Across the Nation we need
more resources to match the scale of the
problem that's why the president's
fiscal year 2023 budget propose a
significant increase in funding to beat
the overdose epidemic and save lives
with that hello Chris good to see you
back in DC yeah uh so uh last night the
justice department released a photo of
top secret documents found at Mar-A-Lago
had President Biden seen the photo been
briefed on the photo and uh does wettest
believe that there was National Security
uh at risk by having these documents
there
um so as I've said many times
I get how you're asking the question I
hear you Chris
we're just not going to comment on the
investigation anything any underlying
pieces of the investigation any content
of the investigation this is an ongoing
as you all know investigation that the
Department of Justice and independent
investigation that the Department of
Justice is doing we are not going to
politically interfere we are not going
to comment on anything connected to the
investigation and we're just going to
keep it there sure the legal process the
FBI but as the president's role as
manager in Chief overseeing National
Security top secret documents some
potentially involving human sources
there uh you know is that something that
the president's keeping tabs on or
that's part of his intelligence
experience so as far as top secret
materials or classified materials look
the president has said he believes he
said this very recently in the
importance of properly handling
classified materials but in regard in
regards to the specific case again we're
just not going to comment from here we
want to make sure we're what we're doing
is like out of abundance of caution
right to not comment on an ongoing
investigation uh not to politically
interfere this is an independent
investigation that the Department of
Justice is doing and this is something
that the president has talked about
during his campaign making sure that
they have that Independence the
Department of Justice has that
Independence as it relates to
investigations and we are just not going
to comment any further and on tomorrow's
speech does the president plan to talk
specifically about Donald Trump in the
speech tomorrow uh and uh does he feel
like you know what do you talk about the
battle over democracy doesn't feel like
things are moving the right direction
the wrong direction what can you tell us
what the presence impossible so I don't
want to I don't want to get ahead of the
the president's speech it's not a good
thing to do as you know
but
you know the president thinks that there
is an extremist threat to our democracy
the president has been clear as he can
be on that particular piece when we talk
about a democracy when we talk about our
freedoms the way that he sees is the mag
of Republicans are the most energized
part of the Republican party uh the that
extreme this is an extreme threat to our
democracy to our freedom uh to our
rights they just don't respect the rule
of law you've heard that from the
president uh and um you know they are
pursuing an agenda that takes away
people's rights so which is what the
president said last week on Thursday you
all heard him this is what the president
said yesterday and that's what he's
going to continue to say and here's the
thing the president's not going to shy
away to call out what he clearly sees is
happening in this country and you know
again Mega Republicans are this extreme
part of their party and that is just
facts and that what he's going to
continue to lay out
on the speech tomorrow can you explain a
little bit the decision to do this as a
prime time
um
the president takes what he's talking
about again not to go into uh not to go
into specifics about the speech but as
you know we're calling it The Soul of
the nation he takes that very seriously
when we come when it comes to our
democracy as you might remember the
president laid out his thesis right the
foundation for what he calls the soul of
the nation fighting for the soul of the
nation the battle of the soul of the
nation and an Atlantic Atlantic op-ed
back in August of 27th uh 20 2017 and
again that is the thesis that is the
foundation when you read that article
and that's what he talked about during
the campaign that's what he talked about
during his inaugural
inauguration day and not only are we
fighting for the soul of the nation but
we need to continue to be vigilant and
you know there's a clear through line if
you if you read that article
and you look at what the speeches that
he's made so that article talked about
Charlottesville you think about January
6 I mentioned inauguration you think
about what we're seeing today you think
about the battle that continues and so
but what the president believes
which is a reason to have this in prime
time is that there are an overwhelmingly
uh amount of Americans a majority of
Americans who believe that we need to
continue we need to save the core values
of our of our country
[Music]
filing you have said in the past that
the president was not briefed ahead of
time on other aspects of the
investigation so just to be clear was
the president briefed on this latest
development the president has not been
briefed on this latest development he
has not been briefed on anything that's
connected to this particular criminal
investigation which is we're not going
to comment again it's an independent
investigation at this time we're just
not going to to comment on it we're
going to let the Department of Justice
continue it's uh its independent
investigation
the President yesterday weighed in
pretty forcefully about threats to the
FBI and FBI agents is he satisfied is
the White House satisfied that FBI
agents are getting the protection that
they need as a result of these threats
so you know just like the president just
want to say this and the president spoke
to this very forcefully and very clearly
yesterday as you all heard him uh he's
rejected the funding the police he
rejects the funding other law
enforcement including the FBI the
president has called for boosting police
funding through the cops program and
hiring a hundred thousand additional
officers he also included over 10.8
billion dollars for the FBI in the most
recent budget and so the the way that he
believes this and we have said is that
the men and women who bravely serve in
law enforcement to keep us safe to keep
our communities safe to keep our country
safe deserve the resources and support
they need to do their jobs and not
seeing their budget slash so he has
provided
additional funding and he wants to make
sure that they are kept safe I cannot
speak to what you know specifically what
they're seeing and how uh you know what
they're seeing at the FBI I would refer
you to them specifically on what
potential
um uh you know what's coming in as as
far as their protection but clearly this
is something that's important for the
president which is why he's included in
his budget man a separate topic what
what additional assistance is the White
House planning for Ukraine and will you
need Congressional approval for funding
that additional package so as you know
40 billion dollars was approved by
Congress which in a bipartisan way of us
of assistance not too long ago we
announced uh under this President
leadership we've provided unprecedented
amount about 13.5 billion dollars in in
security instance and and the assistance
that most recently was announced last
week I believe will begin in the next
several months and continue over the
coming years it's intended to support
Ukraine's defense capabilities for the
long term so you've already seen our
commitment to Ukraine for the long term
as it's related to what we announced
last week which is about three billion
dollars which was the largest once once
at once tranche that we've announced and
uh you know we're going to continue to
meet both the Urgent and the long-term
needs and that's what you saw from uh
that the most recent the most recent
announcement look just that announcement
uh and the announcement prior to that
it's about 19 presidential drawdown of
security assistant that was the one
before the 3 billion that was the one
before the 3 billion was the
presidential drawdown that's that was
the 19th so you have seen consistent
support for for Ukraine we have always
said we have been incredibly impressed
by their bravery and what they've been
able to do to fight for their freedom to
fight for their democracy and that's
important for folks to know this has
been a bipartisan effort and all because
of an unprovoked brutal war that was
started by the Kremlin so we're going to
continue you're going to continue to see
those efforts and we are in Daily
conversation uh with the Ukrainian
government on what what else their needs
might be lastly will the U.S send the
representative to Mikhail Gorbachev's
funeral or do anything else to
commemorate and stuff so I don't I don't
have anything to preview or to announce
at this time on that piece
just back to yesterday's speech from the
president
um he obviously was critical of some
senior lawmakers he said for saying
things to be effective if such and such
happens There Will Be Blood in the
street he was obviously also very clear
that any threats attacks on the FBI law
enforcement agents that those were not
acceptable given all of that I'm just
wondering whether the president would be
open to having direct conversations with
some senior lawmakers some of whom he
has known for many years to tell them to
cut it out
so I don't have any calls to preview or
any conversation
um on this specific subject as you know
we try to keep our conversations with
loremakers uh private uh and uh so
nothing there uh to to preview or to to
add look you know we have been long uh
been clear uh that when the Department
of Justice Independence sorry that the
Department of Justice and the FBI
um you know as I just said said like we
need to we need to not attack our brave
men and women who protect our country
and who protect our communities uh and
you just heard me lay down uh what
funding this president has put forward
and has announced and to to do just that
so you know the president was just
reinfo emphasizing that violence or
threats of violence has absolutely no
place no place in our society which we
should all agree on regardless of the
point of view it doesn't matter if which
side of the aisle that you're sitting on
we need to denounce that and so when you
are inciting violence or when you are
making comments the way that we've heard
over the weekend for some from some
leadership and some members
members in elected office that's a
dangerous thing and the president's not
going to shy away from calling out
calling out those types of comments I
guess I guess without previewing
specific conversations that may have
happened or could happen in the future
you know if he believes this kind of
rhetoric is potentially a harmful or
dangerous to law enforcement you know
does he feel that he has a
responsibility to do everything he can
actually I think he made that very clear
Yesterday
by for example again reaching out to
some of these members directly and
having that conversation look MJ I hear
your question but all you have to do is
turn on the TV and hear from the
president directly on how he feels about
what he's hearing and he's been very
clear about that and again he's not
going to shy away he believes and I have
said this a couple of times at this
Podium at this point is as president he
has the obligation to speak out against
threats against our democracy against
violence it is uh he believes as
president you have this you have the
strongest platform if you will the
strongest voice and that's what he's
going to continue to do again he's not
going to step away from it he's not
going to shy away from that I think any
of those legislators or any of those
elected officials all they have to do
I'm sure they have seen the clip over
and over again from your network and
others about what the president has said
yesterday and how forceful he was how
passionate he was and that's just that
is going to continue
one last week
given that you know you all have billed
it as being related to the battle for
the soul of America which is something
that he obviously ran on back in 2020
the threats to democracy that he
obviously saw as being very real two
three years ago does he believe that
those forces are very much still at
large now or does he believe that there
has been some progress since he came
into office
look he believes that it continues he
believes that we need to continue to
fight for our democracy and he's been
very clear you look at the extreme
wing of a of a party the Mago
Republicans it's not stopping it is
continuing and we heard it over the
weekend as you're asking me about the
president talking directly with
legislators and this is uh this is an
important time and he is again he's not
going to shy away from it he's going to
continue to lift that up and what he
sees and what he's going to call out and
um and you know he believes that there
are majority of Americans who disagree
with that who disagree on the attack of
our core values as a country and he's
going to speak directly to them tomorrow
that's what you're going to hear
and then I'm going to come to you back
and then I'll come in thanks green
um over the past week or so we've heard
many Republicans argue that this
President ran as igniter and now he's
calling Mega Republicans which is a very
large swath of the American populist
semi-fascists he is arguing that they're
a threat to democracy does the White
House believe that this is a fair
criticism by Republicans that this is
not unifying language
so I'll say this Nancy sadly there are
more examples than I can count on how we
have seen recently armed attacks on
federal law enforcement there are a
couple of things I just want to say here
you have representative Paul goldsara
has posted videos depicting him
attacking the president and members of
Congress you have representative
majority
majority Taylor green has publicly
expressed support for shooting prominent
Democratic elected officials and
suggesting physically assaulting
transgender school officials you have
representative Madison cawthorne has
said falsely if our election systems
continue to be rigged and continue to be
stolen then it's going to lead to one
place and that's bloodshed
and just last week he had Governor Ron
DeSantis suggested that Dr fauci should
be physically assaulted
and former president Trump has done the
same many many times look and many of
your colleagues have actually talked
about and reported on this dangerous
Trend that we're seeing
and for example the New York Times
headline from this month as right-wing
rhetoric escalates so do threats and
violence and so these are things that we
have to call out again I was talking I
can't remember who just asked me the
question I was talking about soul of the
nation is something the president has
talked about since 2017 when he wrote
that article in the Atlantic and he's
called it out then he called it out
January 6. he called it out inauguration
day he called it out last week he called
it out yesterday so there is been a
consistent
um uh call out from the president about
what he's seeing from an extreme part of
of this party of the Republican party
and historians I would argue would would
say the same I have a question about
Jackson Mississippi you talked about the
um help that's coming from FEMA and the
disaster of Declaration but clearly
Jackson is going to need an entirely new
water system they've been having big
problems even before this latest crisis
what kinds of federal resources are
being dedicated can be dedicated to what
could be a billion dollar price tag to
provide Jackson with an entirely new
water system so a couple of things as we
said the administration is is committed
to helping the people of Mississippi
during this urgent urgent Time of Need
and so we're going to prioritize that
and and making the long and making the
long-term infrastructure investment
needed to all to to ensure all Americans
just across across have access across
the country but clearly in the state
have access to clean water so that is
something that we're committed that
long-term that long-term need so just a
couple of things just to list out that
that we have provided and that we are
doing from the federal government 450
million dollars was provided through the
American Rescue plan for water upgrades
across the state the city has allocated
20 million dollars of its ARP that
American Rescue plan funds for water and
sewer infrastructure needs you have 75
million dollars through the bipartisan
infrastructure law to support the state
to provide clean and Safe Water this
year with an additional 429 million
dollars available to the state over the
next five years there is 30.9 million
through the epa's revolving loan funds
for treatment and distribution system
improvements for Jackson Mississippi
specifically for again for long-term
support earlier this year we announced
300 000 as part of the administration's
just justice 40 Initiative for the Army
Corps to conduct a validation study to
reduce flooding from the Pearl River in
Jax Jackson Mississippi so we continue
to work with Mississippi's Congressional
Delegation to improve the projects
moving forward but as you can see we are
committed and and we're going to
continue to help the people in
Mississippi
I'm going to go to the back and then
I'll come back up
on Iran the eu's foreign policy Chief
said this morning that he expects a deal
in the coming days is this also your
assessment and is this maybe the reason
why the president had a call with
Israeli Prime Minister lucky today so
let me give you a little bit about lapid
we'll have a we'll have a readout
momentarily on that so the president
spoke with the it was all right okay
there we go you guys are ahead of the
game I think I'm thinking about
something else okay the president spoke
with prime minister lapid this morning
to consult on global and Regional
security challenges including threats
opposed by Iran and iran-backed proxies
the president expressed appreciation for
the warm reception during his July trip
to Israel a visit that visit that
Illustrated the unbreakable bonds and
friendship between our two countries he
also committed to sustained coordination
to implement the announce trip
deliverables the president further
emphasized the importance of conduct
concluding the maritime boundary
negotiations between Israel and Lebanon
in the coming weeks as it relates to the
EU and look we have said many times from
here we're just not going to negotiate
in public as as you know last week we
conveyed our feedback about Iran's
comments on the eu's proposal directly
to the EU and so we're not going to say
more than that we're not going to
negotiate from here and we're not going
to go into details on contents or our
response so we're going to keep it there
yeah so the International Energy agency
summer report shows that the Russian
revenue from oil exports increased 40
percent uh from last year it seems that
the sanctions are not cutting off
Revenue to the Russian president so this
is exactly why I think you've heard us
say this before President Biden under G7
leaders have directed relevant members
of their team to explore a mechanism to
set a global price cap you heard us talk
about that when the president was in
Europe most recently in Germany and this
would be for Russian oil and and
starving Putin of his main source of
cash and forcing down the price of
Russian oil to help blunt the impact of
Putin's war on the pump so it will be
discussed further this week at the G7
Finance ministers meeting this is
happening on Friday the U.S has already
taken strong action on on action to ban
Russia oil and U.S allies have announced
uh chance to wind down their own Imports
of Russian oil but again Putin as you've
heard us say has continued to try to
find new markets for Russian oil this is
the most effective way we believe to fit
to hit hard at Putin's revenue and doing
so will result in not only a drop in
Putin's oil Revenue but but also Global
Energy prices as well why not signal the
policy change for long-term support to
oil opened oil production here in the
U.S or natural gas pipelines here in the
U.S to undercut the Russian supply of
oil on the global market I mean look we
think that working with our allies and
making this announcement this price cap
on Russian oil is going to be very
effective again you've heard directly
you heard the president speak about this
very recently we'll hear more on Friday
how this is going to work and it is not
just us it is also a partnership with
our allies the G7 so again we believe
this is going to be a a way to really
hit Russia financially and so that's
kind of the process that we're going to
take moving forward and also as you know
we've taken we've also taken actions
already that we think has had an effect
but again as we know as I just stated
Russia is always looking at other
markets which is why doing this
particular piece we think will be
effective those other markets are China
and India is the president then going to
use his relationship to stand up to
China and India and say stop buying oil
from Russia look we've been also very
clear about that I don't have anything
more to add but again we think by doing
these price caps is going to hit Russia
in a way that is going to be the most
effective so again the G7 Finance
Ministries are meeting on Friday to talk
more about that and we'll have more to
share
okay
that Phil I haven't called any other bed
and I'll come down
um when it comes to voters how does the
president differentiate between the
ultra Maga folks who he sees as an
extremist threat to democracy and the
average GOP voter so
um can't talk about voters from here as
you know
no I I get you uh not gonna I just need
to say that right just
just to be clear
um I mean the president has been has
been really clear about the leadership
right the mega Republicans uh in
leadership they're the ones who have the
platform they're the ones who again the
extremist part of the Republican Party
they're the ones who uh you know folks
listen to uh in their own party and by
inciting Violence by trying to take away
they're the ones who are the legislators
and trying to take away our rights
trying to take away our freedoms and
that's who the president is speaking to
right he's being very targeted in that
way and calling that out and saying you
know we can't allow our democracy to be
attacked in this way and they have a
responsibility right they have a
responsibility and how uh they are doing
their business on behalf of their
constituents so for folks sitting at
home
when the president is talking about
preserving the soul of the nation and
there's threats to democracy he's not
referring to those individuals he's
talking about Republican leadership
well let me be be very clear it's not
just Republican leadership it's not just
that blanket right he is talking about
an ex in an extreme portion like extreme
uh part of of the party he's been very
very clear about that he was just in
Maryland as you all know and he talked
about Governor Larry Hogan and talked
about how he is a Conservative
Republican who does not who is not in
that bucket right he was very clear and
he he was very purposeful in saying that
and being respectful to a Conservative
Republican who are not part of that
extreme so again want to be very clear
here this is not a blanket statement
this is calling out what we have seen
for some time
um since 2017 as the president wrote
about in his article right when you are
when you are supporting an authoritarian
figure as we have seen who is leading
currently leading the former uh the
former president uh you know and and
um and saying the inciting the violence
that you are or wanting to take away our
freedoms uh you know it we need to say
something he's not going to shy away
from that okay okay
of green now that the FDA has authorized
this new covet booster
um can you say whether the
administration's confident you'll have
enough of these new boosters for
everyone who wants one so um to answer
your question yes because we have
planned for this
um but want to say a couple of things
about the FDA so the announcement is an
important step to getting updated covid
vaccine boosters which we expect to
provide additional protection against
the variants of covid circulating in the
U.S to the American people while we wait
for the CDC to make its clinical
recommendations so there's still another
step so we want to be very clear about
that we've been working for months to be
prepared for this moment and to get
shots into arms this fall and through
the end of the year so we are prepared
to do that so with fda's authorization
doses can be shipped now to tens of
thousands of sites Nationwide and shots
and arms can start as soon as possible
after CDC issues it's recommendation
later this week all states have ordered
doses already so there has been some
orders that have been done and to make
sure vaccines get to communities quickly
Primary Care Providers at community
health centers and Rural health clinics
across the country are able to order
vaccine directly from federal government
and Long-Term Care Pharmacy networks can
also order a vaccine directly and as we
work to ensure that our highest risk
risks
Americans get protected teams have
already started the process of packing
and shipping doses across the country
and pending against CDC action we expect
shots and arms to begin in Earnest
starting after Labor Day weekend we've
been working with providers
Clinic clinicians local health
department and other critical groups to
vaccinate for vaccination efforts and
we've been doing all of this preparation
despite the lack of funding from
Congress but we have been prepared for
this particular moment to make sure that
we get shots in arms so we've been given
that lack of funding you feel you'll
have the supply you'll be able to get
enough doses to get to everybody who
wants one yeah so again despite the the
the Congress failing to provide us with
funding that would have bolstered our
campaign clearly would not you know that
would have happened we've been preparing
by working closely again with local
local departments clinicians and other
groups look we're still leveraging a
comprehensive public education program
as I've just stated but look the bottom
line is despite a failure by Congress to
act as we've been asking as you know for
the past several months we've prepared
with resources so we can meet the moment
with these with these boosters and if I
could just follow real quick on the
student loan announcement from last week
we've been hearing from some loan
servicers and advocacy groups who are
concerned that there's not going to be
enough time in this four-month period to
get everybody's applications processed
and their balance is adjusted before
repayment starts I guess could you kind
of respond to that concern and then is
there um anything the White House could
do maybe extend the pause if all those
balances haven't been adjusted by
January 1st so just want to you know
just want to reiterate that this is a
priority for the president this is a
priority for the Secretary of Education
you've heard them both say that and look
there's also we've got experience here
they've got experience with this the
Department of Education has already
canceled 32 billion dollars in student
loan debt for over 1.6 million borrowers
which has never happened before which is
unprecedented that has happened the last
19 months and so you know the
administration will be launching a
simple application just to go down to
through the the process by early October
for folks who don't know if you would
like to be notified when the application
is open you can go to the studentaid.gov
to sign up for notifications once a
borrower completes the application they
can expect relief within four to six
weeks that's what we have determined
bars are advised to apply before
November 15 so there are there is a
deadline there in order to receive a
relief before the payment pause expires
on December 31st as you all know of this
year the Department of Education will
continue to process application as they
res as they are received even after the
pause expires on December 31st but again
just we are encouraging people to do it
before November 15th we and we are going
to do everything that we can because
Department of Education is has been
committed to doing this and there is
precedent for them doing that for 1.6
million Americans previously okay
up on this beach tomorrow will the
president be outlining any new policies
or proposals designed to safeguard
democracy protect voting rights so I'm
I'm not going to go into details into
his speech I will not get ahead of the
president
um you know I talked a little bit about
the soul of the nation of what he's
talked about before uh and I'm just not
going to get into further details of the
speech itself
does the president have any plans or is
any discussion about him going down
there to personally
who are affected by this nothing to
nothing to read out or preview about a
trip to Mississippi at this time
as I'm as I stated the FEMA
administrator spoke spoke to the
governor I believe last night the
president this morning spoke to the
mayor as you as you all know and we're
just going to be in close touch from our
Administration to theirs to local and a
local governments local folks as well to
make sure that they have the need that
they have the the um the resources that
they need
up here thanks green there's a big
problem now that rainbow fentanyl which
is designed to Target children has been
found in 18 states What specifically is
the president doing about this so we
just talked about uh the day the
overdose awareness day that that we are
observing today I just laid out what the
second gentleman
and others are doing within within this
Administration and
um you know we are going to continue to
focus on the the steps that were taken
that we have taken you have the 80
million dollars that DHS just announced
today on drug prevention and the
president has taken many steps he's made
this a priority to make sure that we
attack a very dangerous uh very
dangerous drug serious drugs in this
country but 300 overdoses a day now we
know how the fentanyl is coming into the
country it's coming right across the
southern border the DEA administrator
says so so when is the president going
to do something so I will say that uh
you have seen a 200 percent increase of
fentanyl seizures which means that uh we
are we are doing the job of catching a
drug traffickers 200 hold on 200
increase just again seizures
are between in a century and part of
that is being driven by drug overdoses
so what is the president and we we agree
we agree we see those same numbers as
well but the fact that we're you know we
are securing the Border uh the fact that
we are securing record levels of funding
uh from DHS so they can stop illicit
drugs from entering into the country
this the fact that it's not just drug
traffickers that we're dealing with as
well we're stopping stopping financiers
this is what's happening with this under
this Administration look what up 300
overdoses this is being designed to
Target my children drug cartels and here
you don't want to kill American Kids
what is this President doing about it I
hear you I just I just laid out 200 of
increase of drug fentanyl seizures that
isn't a dangerous drug that we are
taking off the street we are going to
continue to focus this is an important
important priority for this President
and I just want to talk about how you're
saying that they're you know they're
just the border right and how the Border
whatever you just stated I just want to
clear this up migrants coming in people
are dying
hold on so migrant migrants who
attempted to enter the country illegal
illegally are taken into custody by
border patrol agents that is how it
works that is the process that we are
taking they are then either expelled by
the court order under if title 42
transferred to ice custody or monitor
through alternatives to detention
program as they await further processing
we have made 3 000 arrests in the first
three months of launching an aggressive
campaign to combat the multi-billion
Dollar human smuggling industry when it
comes to when it comes to what's
happening with drug overdose this is
something that the president cares about
this is something that the president has
laid out a plan to make sure that our
kids our babies our you know Young
Americans here in this country are not
continuing to suffer from that or not
continuing to be given or access to
drugs this is something that's
incredibly important to this President
so to say that we're not doing enough
off Peter is just falsely categorically
wrong especially on a day that we are
observing what needs to be done and and
we have announced DHS has announced 80
million dollars to prevent that so we
are doing the work and here's the thing
Peter if look if Republicans want to
help us stop overdose and stop our kids
getting over those because of these
dangerous drugs because of these
fentanyl that we're seeing in the
streets we're happy to work with them
but they're not I'm moving on I'm moving
on I'm moving on
okay
yeah who's the audience for tomorrow's
speech in Philadelphia how are people
selected today I'm oh the odd the folks
in in the room
you know I don't have that information
for you uh clearly is going to be
um
folks from the Philly area who will be
uh clearly participants that's normally
How We Do events we invite uh local
leaders uh we invite uh local you know
local residents uh to to the event to
watch the president speak I I don't have
a full list or a full way of our process
but that's normally how we do our events
as you know as you know you've attended
some of our events and it's usually
people connected to the party or people
in that part but can connect it to
elected officials locally and the state
as well and on the CDC booster
specifically as it relates to the
president if the CDC director or sues as
the new boosters if the CDC director
signs off on the boosters as expected
tomorrow and they do start rolling out
next week can we expect the president to
get his booster shot next week so I
don't have any dates to announce yet on
uh on when he will get it but obviously
the president was just infected with uh
omokron and is really well protected as
you all know right now against against
covid so CDC has always provided that
guidance on timing for boosters as it
relates to Prior infection and they'll
do that here as well as it relates to
the president and your question but he
will absolutely get his updated booster
and will encourage eligible Americans to
do the same when uh when he's able to
again just to follow him I know you've
been asked a couple times about it but
in a January speech the president
singled out Jackson Mississippi as well
as Flint as two communities that could
be uh benefited from the infrastructure
package and specifically to mentioned
their water system does the
administration still believe that
Jackson threw the infrastructure package
can receive the funds that it needs to
actually fully replace its water system
and just to follow to that is what is
the timeline I know the money's on the
way you guys have really statements
saying the funding is on the way but
what is the timeline for residents on
the ground to actually start feeling the
impact of that infrastructure package so
the impact when it comes to them getting
the residents getting their water backs
clearly we want them that timeline to
happen as soon as possible and so that
is our hope rather sooner rather than
than later and so we're going to
continue we're committed to to work with
the people of Jackson and the state of
Mississippi during this urgent time of
need as we just said on making that
happen because that's imperative and
important for people to have clean water
and running water look I just listed out
a number of of items from the American
Rescue plan 450 million dollars uh 20
million of that was given to the city
and that was through the American Rescue
plan and that was for water and sewer
infrastructure needs so already that
funding was given to the city to to deal
with that imperative that really
important need 75 million as we talk
about the bipartisan infrastructure
fracture law 75 million was given to
support the state to provide clean and
safe water for this year and so with an
additional 429 million dollars available
to the state over the next five years so
you see that long-term commitment that's
coming from the bipartisan
infrastructure law and as it relates
another piece of that which is coming
through epa's revolving loan phones
funds that we see for treatment and
distribution system that we saw 30 30.9
million dollars going to Jackson
specifically so we are committed the
funds have been provided we are going to
continue to work with the cities and
we're going to continue to work with the
state as you know Mitch Landru is the is
is the coordinator for the bipartisan
infrastructure law he's a former mayor
as you all know from uh New Orleans and
Louisiana so which is very close to
Mississippi clearly he is committed to
this he's traveled around the country
meeting meeting with elected's meeting
with folks on the ground on how on how
things are going and how we can be
helpful as far as a date or a timeline I
don't have that for you but clearly we
have I just listed out our commitment
and where the fundings and the money has
gone to the state of Mississippi and
Jackson as well when residents in the in
these communities hear those numbers
they're going to be wondering why does
this keep
so I mean as the administration
identified any impediments whether it be
the formula-based funding or the actual
State process of implementing These
funds so that actually prevent the
impact from being felt immediately it's
a very good question and if I were if we
were
in the community we would be frustrated
as well which is why the bipartisan
infrastructure law as I just laid out
has a there's there there's an initial
funding and it goes for the next five
years right that is a long-term
investment that you are seeing from this
Administration to the folks in
Mississippi and to the people in in
Jackson so again we're going to continue
to work with uh the you know local
elected officials to see what else we
can do to be helpful we are we're
remaining uh to want to assist uh the
you know the the community as they're
going through this really tough time but
you have seen the financial commitment
you have seen how the funds for the
infrastructure wise you were asking
specifically has been allocated and not
just that the American Rescue plan as
well again we're going to have the we're
going to continue to have that
conversation
is there a specific date for when the
application opens for student loan
relief at this point and and why the um
the kind of lag time the delay in
actually having a system set up given
there was a lot of time taken to
deliberate over this decision so as I
just stated
um
moments ago uh they're they're we're
going to have a we're going to have more
from the Department of Education to be
notified when the application is open
and again we're gonna we we have a
website that people can go to
studentaid.gov to sign up for
notifications so those notifications uh
will go will go up and borrows will have
uh we'll have to complete that
expectation and and it'll be within four
to six weeks we which is a good amount
of time to make sure that uh that they
uh that they apply before November 15th
but it doesn't just end there right we
have said that the Department of
Education will continue to process
application even as they are received
even after the pause expires on December
31st so we are going to continue to work
uh with bars but we do have to put a
plan in place so that folks know how how
the process works again they can go to
the to the website and apply get those
notifications and we have been giving
out information on how the process can
work this is not the first time we've
done this before right this in this
Administration those that 32 billion
dollars in student loan debt uh that we
were able to to uh cancel uh so the
Department of Education there's a
precedent here the Department of
Education knows how to work this through
and uh and we're we are committed uh to
make sure that uh folks get the
information and get the need that they
that get the need there's no date yet oh
for the application well I don't have a
date here to share with you but that's
something that the SEC the Department of
Education is following through we've
laid out our process we've laid out the
timeline we have said we're going to
continue to process application even
after the pause on December 31st and
we're committed to that again this is
not the first time there's precedent for
this uh we have this this particular
administration department of education
has done this before I'm gonna continue
okay
oh yeah on the event yesterday in
Pennsylvania the president explicitly
campaigned for certain people and
currently if I'm wrong but I believe it
was an official White House Event not a
campaign event
and share some context on your thoughts
on that because he was very explicitly
saying please elect certain people
so um
the president can say a lot who can go a
lot further than I can from here he does
not have uh he is not bounded by the
Hatch Act the way that we are and so so
I'll say that first
and I don't have much more to add
because I've always even myself I try to
be very very careful from here but again
he is in a different category than we
all are here uh and uh and I'll just
leave it as that
event correct it was it was an official
event tomorrow night will be an official
event as well
no it's supposed to calling you last
time and I didn't
rain so yesterday
to reiterated what he sees as a serious
need to pass an assault weapons ban this
is of course something he said before
that's not new but as he continues to
push for this how does he expect that to
happen realistically with the way things
are in Congress and what specifically is
he doing if anything to help that you
know so I'll say this you know the pre
look the president's going to continue
to call on on Congress as you know when
it comes to the assault weapons ban that
is something that is important to the
president he was one of the leaders of
that 30 years ago uh the assault weapons
ban back in 1994 and again he has been
trying to work on uh work on bringing
back the assault weapons ban after it's
sunset in uh 10 years after and he's
done that as vice president and he's
doing that now
a couple of things that I do want to say
is when it comes to actions that he's
taken he's had more executive actions
dealing with dealing with gun violence
than any other president at this time
when the bipartisan law passed to to
deal with to deal with gun violence just
recently just a couple of months ago
many people said that wouldn't happen
and it happened so many people have said
we couldn't get things done and we got
that done so the president as you heard
him say he is determined to do that he's
determined to make that happen he's
going to continue doing the work that he
has done for the past 19 months and
having those conversations with Congress
Congressional members in in calling for
them to take action and we have seen the
house takes action which many didn't
think that was going to happen either
and they took action on the assault
weapons ban so we are a lot further we
would argue on that this Administration
dealing with gun violence even dealing
with pushing further the assault weapons
ban then we have been in 30 years and so
I think that says a lot for This
president's leadership and that says a
lot for what he's his commitment in
making sure that we protect our
communities we protect kids uh going to
school right we protect people from
going to grocery stores right and not
feel like they their lives are in danger
it's the first step and there are many
steps to take
all the attention on the former
president's handling of classified
information not asking you to comment on
that specifically but can you say with
certainty to the American people that
President Biden in his time as president
has not mishandled improperly stored
done anything improper with classified
information no and I'm going to move on
good thank you I have two questions one
on the speech tomorrow and one on prove
it on the speech tomorrow um President
Biden said in his victory speech in
November 2020 that he sought this office
to restore the soul of the nation so
where does the White House believe the
country is in that restoration process
look he he has said this before that
it's going to take some work you've
heard him say that you've heard us say
that
um but what he is not going to do is shy
away again from calling out uh extremism
that he is seeing these Mega Republicans
he is not going to shy away from that is
there more work to do absolutely do we
have to continue to protect our
democracy uh yes we do that is the
reality that we're in protect our
freedom uh you know protect our rights
and that's what he's going to continue
to do uh day in and day out and you're
going to continue to hear that from him
not just Thursday not just yesterday but
that message is going to continue
that many employers have robust return
to office plans that will begin after
Labor Day and just yesterday some Wall
Street Banks announced that they are
going to be ending entirely testing
vaccination masking requirements how
would the White House respond to those
companies I I leave the up to to the
companies to decide what's right for um
decide what's right for their employees
clearly there's CDC guidance that we
always recommend people to follow but I
leave that up to the private private
organization
first of all how does the president plan
to commemorate 911 this year
uh that's a very good question don't
have anything to preview at this time
and when we will we'll share that and
then moving on to Venezuela a U.S
citizen detained in Venezuela has said
on on the record quote our government
has abandoned us so how does the
administration respond to a statement
like that and what is the administration
doing to try to get the 10 Americans who
are detained in Venezuela out is a
prisoner exchange possibly in the cards
and you know Howard how are you working
you're talking about the person is
talking about our government right not
the Venezuela okay um I have not seen
that reporting uh I'll say this you know
we try we're very careful in not
negotiating in public and being mindful
of not putting any you know any lives at
more at risk so I'm just not going to
share anything further from here at this
time
oh my gosh I'm gonna go around have I
okay okay and then I'll come I'll come
back guys thanks uh can you talk a
little bit uh in regards to tomorrow's
speech can you talk a little bit about
the timing you've said a bunch of times
that this is a theme that he's discussed
for for many years so so why now is the
time to do it in such a prime time
fashion
because he thinks our democracy is at
risk because I mean you know when I talk
about taking away our freedom
June 24th the decision from the security
Supreme Court Justice on the Dobbs
decision that was a decision to to take
away our constitutional right
that was an important uh important
moment for our country
it put women's lives at risk and it's
not just you know Reproductive Rights
it's going to be other rights as well as
we heard from uh Supreme Court Justice
Thomas he made that very very clear and
then after that we heard from leaders of
the Republican Party saying they wanted
a national ban
so we've seen recent efforts to take
away our rights as Americans from an
extreme again an extreme uh part of uh
of their party those Mega Republicans
that you'll you'll continue uh to hear
us talk about and so that is continuing
and it hasn't stopped and I just listed
out what recently what recently
leadership leaders in Congress have said
about attacking law enforcement
individuals who are protect us
uh you know attacking their own
colleagues from the other side of the
aisle that's dangerous again the
president's not going to shy away from
speaking up from speaking out and uh he
is it is very important for him to speak
directly to the American people as I
have said and this is kind of goes into
to Phil's question he believes majority
of Americans want to protect our
democracy he believes majority of
Americans wants to protect our freedom
that's where he believes the majority of
the country is but we have to keep
talking about it we cannot shy away from
it can you talk give any color of how
he's preparing for the speech I mean the
the guide into schedule today seem not
so full I mean is he spending much of
his day you know going through drafts
with staff is he practicing it what kind
of what's kind of the problem you know
as you know this is an important speech
for the president we're talking about a
theme to your point that he's talked
about since 2017. so yes he's working
through uh the speech with his with his
senior advisors with his staff he's
continuing to do the business of the
American people by meeting with staff on
issues on items that are critical and
policies that we continue to work
through
to make sure that we do the work he
continues always going to continue to do
the work of the American people but yes
to your point he's going to look at he's
going to look at drafts he's going to
write his speech and you'll hear
directly from him tomorrow
good thank you uh Korean uh Angola just
had a very peaceful and well organized
election uh last week and as you said
the U.S was following and the results
are there so the for the president uh
John Lorenzo was re-elect and I would
like to hear the view of the White House
on the Angola elections yeah so don't
don't have anything more to add and to
your point we congratulated last week on
Friday we congratulated the people of
Angola for making their voices heard as
we're talking about you know democracy
as we're talking about elections this is
an important moment for the people in
Angola we continue to observe we're
going to continue to observe the process
I I know I've said that last week but I
I don't just I just don't have more more
to add
um and uh you know the United States
supports the Democratic process and uh
through our ongoing democracy and
governance programs by observing giving
the election as we as we've done and you
know we share a partnership with the
country with the country of Angola I
don't have more to say to what I just
added
you know President Biden announced a big
investment for Angola so last time he he
just told me that the reason why is
because they are seeing some progress in
the country can you elaborate a little
more about the view of the US in Angola
in the last five years so as I was just
saying that we see a partnership with
Angola we will continue to work with
them with the government closely
whoever you know the The Chosen
government that the people elected to
deepen our cooperation and shared
priorities so we're going to continue to
do that and again including democracies
I've been talking about including
economic and investment growth Global
Health security and public health and
climate energy goals to create a better
future for the for all angolians and
that is a commitment that you'll hear
that you have heard I think that's what
the president was saying to you on
Friday and again we commend the people
of Angola for you making their voices
heard and that is important that we see
a democratic process happening there
I have called you um
booster shots we're now two and a half
years into a pandemic lots of people are
really tired of thinking about covid how
will the administration convince people
to get yet another booster shot look we
have learned we have a lot of lessons
learned from how we started this this
process very early on in his
administration with the comprehensive
strategy that we had in getting shots
and arms we know it works I talked about
a little bit about that already which is
working closely with doctors and
clinicians making sure that we're having
educating folks on the ground on why
this is important why this campaign on
on getting people uh the this this
booster to folks and again shot in arms
and one of the things that we have seen
that worked really really well is is the
trusted voices that is also an important
thing that we have seen but just a
reminder that before we entered office
less than a third of adults wanted to
get a shot and more than 87 percent have
at least one today that is the product
of the work we've done to reach folks
through trusted Messengers and build
access those are two key factors that we
cannot forget first we're planning a
public education campaign building on
lessons we've learned as I just stated
and focus focusing on those most at risk
that's always important here this will
include leveraging deep Partnerships as
I mentioned across sectors to meet
people where they are and uh and to you
know and and just as a reminder
um you know it to do this HHS tests
messages weekly surveying at least 1500
people who are on the fence about
getting their booster shot and tracking
shifts and Trends and works with trusted
Messengers to communicate with the
public and so we have a plan and we're
going to ultimately use that plan we're
going to leverage what we know worked
before and we believe this is an
important moment for the American people
but again FDA made that decision CDC
still has to make their decisions so we
don't want to get ahead of ahead of this
but we are prepared orders have already
been made and we're going to make sure
that you know we get those shots in arms
one more oh my gosh who have I not
called on in a long time I've never seen
you in the room before go ahead
okay hello I lost about the hill and
white has clarities on the hill
Democrats have managed the past the
inflation reduction act and chips among
other big bills uh student loan
forgiveness is costly I know the White
House has not projected an estimate yet
um but you know many take this to see
that right like there may not be many
more priorities that involve Center
Mansion support
um and what do you make of this uh and
you know if if that's not true what is
the White House priority for the next
you know legislative plan so Sophia
welcome to the briefing room happy to
see you uh so we're focused on working
with members of Congress of both parties
and uh on on Government funding bills
that's that that would invest in our
communities and people and people reduce
costs for fam Working Families and help
grow our economy from the bottom up in
the middle out as you hear us say so
that's something that's coming up that
we'll be very focused on uh in in this
Administration and clearly with
Congressional members we're working with
leadership in both Chambers toward an
efficient straight straightforward
September work period and we know
democratic appropriators have been
working hard to prepare for that
particular legislative piece that the
government funding funding bills and
we're going to press ahead with
confirmations don't forget that that is
also very important including judicial
confirmations continuing to put
well-qualified judges on the bench that
are devoted to the rule of law and that
represent the diversity of the of our
nation as you have seen historically
done by this Administration we're also
implementing The Landmark laws we have
passed as you just mentioned for the
middle class which is the infra
including the inflation reduction act
that's already creating manufacturing
jobs and will lower many of families
biggest cost chips as you uh as I'm sure
you're thinking about to bolster our
competitives with China and also keep
bringing jobs back from overseas and
more so there's a lot to do judicial
there's the there's the government
funding bills and there's also making
sure that we're implementing these
historic pieces of legislation that were
early on okay we gotta go we gotta go
but I'll be back tomorrow guys thank you
everybody